[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad well this week i've got
something a little bit different for you
all he may not be a household name in
new zealand just yet but he certainly is
making a name for himself over in
america whereas a punter for indiana
playing college football it's not often
we see kiwis chase the american football
dream so there's heaps in this thing
that i'm looking forward to talking
about
and of course like all my guests are he
is an absolute lad he's one of the
greats it is james evans welcome mate
i appreciate it thanks for having me
mate thanks for coming on it is such a
unique um and exciting opportunity that
you've got in front of you at the moment
so
i'm really looking forward to hearing
all about it that sounds good mate so
you've obviously just finished your
first season um
how was it over there what have you
what's life like over there in america
um it's it's pretty hectic um
i mean with school and football it's
kind of like two
two full-time jobs um so i just recently
got accepted into the kelly school of
business which is like a top 10 i think
business school in america so i was
really stoked with that
so just balancing that and football and
last season was crazy um
the team especially compared to years
past and we didn't really do so well
um but we played
i believe like the strength of schedule
was the hardest in all of college
football playing in the big ten and then
we played non-conference games against
cincinnati and a few other really good
schools uh so i got some really really
crazy experiences in and
i guess a lot of cool stories and a lot
of good memories right how good is that
so for those who don't know much about
college football
give us a little bit of an insight into
what it's like over there it looks
unbelievable massive uh massive
following massive stadiums
what's it like uh it's absolutely unreal
uh the fans are crazy um
we have a stadium slightly bigger than
eden park
uh it was full
i wanna say four out of about six home
games so that was unreal like running
out
um but then also
we got to play in some like the coolest
stadiums
we played uh night games at penn state
and michigan and they were like they
were packed out
so it was like 107 000 people in the
stands against penn state and then 110
000 against michigan so
especially when you're running out like
the tunnel in those games you're like
you look up and you go whoa
yeah
what if i get myself into um
really really good memories there
um
you know it's it's just crazy like the
scale of things is crazy
uh the fans uh i still remember my first
game
we played at the university of iowa
and came in we went through like private
tsas like airport security whatever
got a police escort to the airport and
then got on like a chartered plane uh
the middle of nowhere in iowa and then
stay in a fancy hotel
everything was just like unreal like
you know um
and then the next day when we played the
game i remember going to the stadium and
it was just like just miles of or
kilometers of uh people tailgating like
middle-aged men
uh pulling their finger at you on the
bus and
all these like just
it was it was just like the scale of it
um
the fan support
and all those things are just like off
the chains
mate it is next level like how do they
get such big support and such a massive
following
ah well i feel like a lot of like the
places where historically
there's been really good programs during
summer like the more rural areas um
which is not necessarily like pro sports
um
and obviously america is such a big
place as well so like
bloomington where i live in indiana uh
it's a college town like there's only
80 000 people that live here and then
when like on summer break when all the
schools go home there's only like 40 000
people
um
so i mean there's not
too much to do necessarily so when
there's football and there's basketball
and there's other sports like people
people come from around the state and
they come and
uh support the team and whatnot
that is unreal and how have you found
the whole um football side of things
obviously you're a punter how have you
found the punting side of the game
i mean it's been good i i started all 12
games last year as a freshman which was
good that was a goal of mine um
some good games some bad games and and
whatnot but uh
just trying to get better for the second
year and then i've got oh
i've got three more seasons left to play
so it was good to start as a freshman
which is pretty hard to do and then
um just hoping to get better and better
in my last three years so there's a
three-year limit that you can be
involved in this side uh no there's a
there's a four-year limit so it's it's
weird
uh there's a there's something called
taking a red shirt yes it's basically a
lot of freshmen do it where they don't
play their first year
uh and so they like preserve your
eligibility and
i mean because you're not really
expected to play as a freshman just
because like physically and mentally
you're not necessarily like ready to
play
uh college football um
i mean especially playing it's like 23
24 year olds and then also
some of that also through kind of a
banner in the works was the uh covert
yeah so basically because of covert
everyone grant an extra yeah
uh unfortunately i did not get that i
started right off the cover yeah but
yeah so there's literally like dudes
that have been playing college football
it was this sixth year last year
um it's like grown grown ass men like 24
year olds
you know so
i suppose you sort of stay out of it all
anyway though do you because you're just
kicking the football the
sort of physical side of it doesn't
matter too much it's more the mental
side of it is it and understanding the
game
yeah so like at practice like really
i don't really do anything
it's kind of funny you watch all these
other dudes like they run around and
they're like knackered and whatnot and
i'm out there like i'll kick like
probably like 40 to 60 balls but like
during like actual team period i only
get like
six seven reps
uh so the rest of practice you know i'm
just
chilling
you know on the sidelines and
dudes sometimes get
i wouldn't say uh annoyed but they'll
get jealous you know when they're
sweating and especially in the summer
when it's really really hot
um
physically like i have to do the same
uh like strength and conditioning as as
everyone else
um
so that was one thing i was i mean i
know you played rugby professional rugby
so long like the pre-seasons are pretty
brutal
i was i you know before i came here i
was like well at least i won't have to
run like
you know conditioning like broncos all
those things you know
and i i get here and they they had me
running with the linebackers in the
tight ends of the quarterbacks so it's
like
it's even worse almost than all the
rugby conditioning um
so that's not not fun but aside from
that it's all
practice is good sure i did wonder
whether you would have to do all that
sort of
conditioning side of um the game as well
because obviously
um being a high high condition athlete's
probably not that important for you
probably what how many kicks would you
average in a game maybe like six or
eight or something would you
uh
yeah five or six yeah if i was six so
i mean i don't really have to be fit to
run on the field like 25 yards and then
run off 25 yards after i take it so
yeah don't give me like
i don't know
it gets me frustrated at times because
i'm
i'm thinking like where is this what's
this going to do me but um
you know i guess it's part of being in a
team
so do they have sort of um requirements
for you to hit physically or is that
just mainly just to push you mentally
um
not really i mean i'll sit down like
with the strength uh coach the hit
strength coach and kind of map out
um you know like progression
i'll have like a weight goal uh
like a muscle mass goal like we have a
um it's like body
fat analysis muscle mass analysis all
those things we get those done every few
months why not um
so just
his i think his big philosophy is just
like
maintaining as much like lean muscle
mass
as he can so just trying to do that and
yeah i guess for me like really sorry
for my lower body my core there's not
too much i really need to do
that's i guess
necessary for me um
but they still make me bench press and
all those things so
yeah
right it sounds like a pretty sweet gig
to be fair but how did you get into uh
at all anyway because obviously you're
from new zealand um you grew up in new
zealand you're playing rugby as i
understand and then um you make the
switch to american football so give us a
little bit of a rundown of your
upbringing
uh well i grew up in auckland uh grew up
playing a lot of sports uh like
predominantly rugby
a bit of cricket in the summer although
kind of got boring you know
as the game drags out uh and i was
pretty much i played you know a lot of
sports um
and what night when i was only i was
like 13 or 14 and
like kicking was probably like my
strongest point in rugby and one of my
coaches was like why don't you just go
play like american football
and i was like
like you say like all you have to do is
kick a ball
you just sit on the sideline all day and
you know i'm out here thinking like
that's a pretty sweet gig
um
and then as i kind of got older
and i guess i started
like getting some injuries and went on
rugby and started like losing my passion
a bit
i
kind of thought back to that idea and i
was and then uh
i was kind of watching like a bit of
college football a bit of nfl football
just because college football is on
sundays like what are you gonna do is
like on a sunday afternoon
uh and then watching the nfl on like
monday morning is a good use of school
you know
um and i saw these australian guys
playing college football and i was like
what are they you know like how it was
possible and then i like did some
research and i found there was uh like a
kicking academy that like trained kids
and then sent them like on college
scholarships the us
um so i got in touch with them my last
year high school
uh went over to melbourne australia for
a tryout and then
um
so i finished high school in november
december 2019
and in january i moved to melbourne
uh
of 2020
um
and then joined pro-kick australia which
is the academy um
and so i was only actually there for
like i want to say like three months
because i covered uh things kind of you
know got locked down and
i think it's probably not good to be 18
alone in a foreign country so my parents
going to move back to new zealand um
but i think it was like literally like
six or seven weeks ended up being in
australia they were like
um we might have a
place for you
um
and then everything kind of just aligned
and then
about a month month and a half later i
was committed here
um
and
then in january of 2021 i moved out to
bloomington indiana
um
and here we are today i guess a year and
a half later so
that's a
interesting story i know um
i know
a lot of people like here i get that
question all the time people are
so
confused like i'll say i play football
and they'll think i play soccer
um
and i'll have to tell him like no like
american football
you know so
yeah
so we how good of you of akika were you
as a as a rugby player did you know you
were like really a really good kicker uh
i i like to think that was that was
definitely my strong point um
i guess goal kicking was kind of my
thing
um
i was able to hit like pretty pretty
long ball i didn't actually really work
on like actually punting ball out of
hand to too much
um
but i i'd like to think i was pretty
good uh before i came when i was
training becca in 2020
uh actually marty banks oh yeah do you
know oh do i what yeah nice top quality
block i ran to a park and we were
kicking some balls
and i guess that was kind of when i
could compare
myself to a elite kicker and we were
pretty
pretty similar i guess uh surely you had
marty banks
maybe kicking a football uh
he's he's a really talented guy though
like top quality dude um
really liked him yeah just really nice
guy how do you think someone like him
could um would go if he tried uh kicking
over there
i mean i feel like he'd go pretty good
uh he might be slightly too old um
now what's he just slightly over 30 but
um
no i feel like he'd fit in pretty well
people would like him
were you just down at the park kicking
your american footballs and he was just
down there kicking rugby balls yeah i
was and i was like i i recognized him um
he actually came up to me i don't want
to be
you know the guy that interrupted a
session um
he came up to me
he was kind of
i guess slightly confused slightly
interested um and then we end up just
kicking balls together for a bit and
talking and i spoke to him for a good
period a couple hours and he was really
really good dude um
so yeah
he's a lad so when you went over to the
pro uh kick academy
did you did you realize pretty quickly
you were pretty gifted in this area
because like you said you weren't there
for very long and
you picked up your gig pretty quickly oh
yeah no there was there was a lot of
really talented dudes so well made
someone playing college football now
um
but i thought especially in terms of
like leg strength uh i could compete
um
with a lot of the
the guys there
um but their big philosophy
in australia was finding like a good fit
um
so the good thing about where i am now
is like obviously i wanted to go to
business school and we got a really
really good business school
um
we got a really good social life um
here and then also
a really good standard football in the
big ten so everything was just like it
was a good um
place for well at least they thought it
was good place for me
um see everything kind of just like
aligned um
you know
yeah had you played any games before you
got over there or was it just purely on
your punting stats and um what you could
do with
on with the foot
uh yes it was really just sending videos
of me punting and then they had like a
pre-existing relationship with uh
our head coach here um and the special
teams coordinator
uh and then uh obviously like i'd kicked
thousands and thousands of balls when i
got here
uh like we had football practice
and so i had to
win like the starting job against uh
three other older guys on the team um
but my first actual like i'd never been
a football game
uh
until we played at iowa and i was
playing in it and it was
yeah there was 70 000 people there and
it was pretty loud um
sounds funny i'm actually it's a funny
thing i didn't like i had never been to
a football game aside from playing in
them until
uh so we live about 45 minutes from
indianapolis so we there's the
indianapolis colts there so they were
playing on thursday night so
um
went up to a game they were playing the
jets
and
the next day we were leaving to play
against michigan
and i was just sitting there thinking
like holy like this is this is unreal
and then
come two days later we're in the big
house which i think is the second
biggest stadium in the world
um
where like tom brady went to school a
lot of like
really big football guys um
there was 110 000 people at the game and
it was like whoa
yeah it's pretty unreal
mate what are your nerves like before
these games
so many people especially your first one
when you hadn't even seen a game you had
never played a game what are your nerves
like
that was it was an interesting few days
uh leading up to it i was
coming off of really like a good few
practice weeks going into it um
so mentally i don't think i was
necessarily too nervous physically the
amount of like adrenaline i had
um
was just like off the chain so it took
me
the first three parts probably
definitely work my best
but as i guess
the game became all settled and you know
what not um
i started to get more confident and i
had a pretty good second half in our
first game
definitely not the greatest first half
but um
i guess we made up for it slightly um
so
yeah i guess there's a hard thing about
being a kicker i guess especially with
the massive crowd the energy you get
from these crowds hundred and ten
thousand i can only imagine i felt like
35 000 was giving me enough energy some
games so
uh but you've got to really control your
uh energy that you're receiving from
them don't you like these guys
who are in all the crash bash staff get
to sort of unleash all this energy
they're picking up but you've got to
control it just to place your ball where
you want it hey
yeah so i mean
i guess i kind of started to approach
the game less like a football player
and more like kind of like just like a
golfer you know
like i just have to do my own thing i'm
almost just like
i'm on the team but i'm not really on
the team you know i'm just like that guy
who does a specialty thing um
and so obviously like if if i was that
guy like bashing heads and
hitting dudes like
i'd love for the crowd to be
you know
but for me i i just have to sit on the
sidelines and stay calm and
uh focus on what i have to do and then
when i get the opportunity um
just do my best to be as calm as
possible and just focus on my technique
and all those good things and what was
it like adjusting to kicking with all
the gear on because obviously
in rugby union there's no gear you've
never played a game you're playing with
now all this gear on
yeah uh
i'm not gonna lie i absolutely hated
this first um
i remember like so at one of our
practices uh
i like took my helmet off before i came
off the field like i had a rap during
team period
um
and the head coach could ask about me in
like a prick press conference and he
mentioned it
and so i was getting a bit clown like on
twitter and whatnot for that is kind of
funny
and then it happened again and they made
me run
uh
a stadium so like run from the bottom of
the stand at the top of the stand
we have pretty big stadiums that kind of
sucked um
but i don't know sometimes it feels like
you're skateboarding like
uh they make me wear knee pads thigh
pads hip head shoulder pads and a helmet
i cut my
knee pads so they're just like
that big instead of being like
whatever uh
i cut my thigh pads so it's just a tiny
piece of foam kind of uh cut my hip pads
so like
they're pretty much non-existent
um
but i guess there was there was
definitely a while where it took me time
to adjust like my helmets it's luckily
it's like lasered to my head so it's
really like full and fitting and
um
it's like it really it's it's so tight
and sometimes it like just doesn't even
feel like you've got something on but
um
definitely those first few practices i
was like
oh my
yeah
so is it compulsory to wear every single
piece of gear that's why you've just
made it as small as possible
yeah so all those things thigh pads hip
pads knee pads like
you have to wear them and the refs
enforce them
um there's like for some reason there's
so many like equipment rules so like
i mean i guess knee pads are supposed to
go over the knees you know it's kind of
implied by the name but
um
i pulled i tried pulling my shorts up as
as high as i could
um i remember i was on the field at
michigan and the ref i thought the rest
did pull your shorts up so i pulled my
shorts up um
it turns out you're saying pull your
shorts down so i think we might have
like nearly drawn a penalty so
that was kind of funny um but for some
reason i don't know there's so many uh
equipment rules
um
which i mean i
guess pretty unnecessary uh i always
tell people like oh joke
they'll be like oh you need shoulder
pads and you need thigh pads and you're
gonna be glad you're wearing shoulder
pads if you ever have to hit someone i
was like well like
i mean i grew up playing rugby like if i
have to make a tag i have to make a
tackle like
what's a helmet gonna do like i'm not
gonna tackle with my head you know
um
you know ideally my head's gonna be on
the side
so i'm not getting like a concussion or
anything but
i don't know have you ever had to take a
contact yet or make a tackle have you
been hit
no uh
i mean aside from one time that like as
a joke the special teams go and i said
go do tackling drill
but it was just tackling someone on a
like a
mat um
i did think uh there was one time
we played at penn state
uh
and the ball was on the two yard line so
my heels are like the back of the end
zone so it was really constricted so
basically it was just like catch it take
a step kick it like it was really like
quick um yeah and they were 10 man
was john dodson who
um
he might get drafted tonight actually
the draw song like now he might get
picked in the first round like he's
shifty dude
like insane athlete and he was back
there and he made three or four dudes
miss
and so i started jogging and i was like
like as they started young further i was
like oh no like
i'm probably about to get like
sidestepped on a
espn you know
uh but luckily one of my teammates like
literally like three meters in front of
me made the tackle otherwise
probably wouldn't have been pretty
yeah
so you talk about that draft that you're
not eligible to be picked up in that
draft yet do you have to finish the your
whole college um football career how
does that work
uh i think you have to spend three years
in
college um
so
some of my teammates i think we have two
or three guys projected to be drafted um
not
i think middle to late rounds uh but
there is definitely guys like around the
country who leave after three years
uh but those guys the guys that are
going to be picked you know
really high so what happens to the guys
who have finished up their time and they
don't get picked up in the nfl where
where do they go or what do they do are
they just
into working life is that yeah i mean i
guess that's uh the good thing
graduating with a degree
um like debt free um
and then also
having the connections uh from playing
college football i mean like yeah
obviously
if you don't get the opportunity to play
professionally like it kind of sucks and
whatnot and a lot of guys
you know are devastated but
[Music]
i feel so like playing college football
opens so many doors like networking
like i've had the opportunity to meet so
many cool people
like
literally one day we were in
football and the dude who starred in
fast and furious tokyo drift
i forgot his name
but he just like walked out in the
facility and he was just like talking to
us to the team meeting and i was like
like
what you know
so it's i don't know
yeah there's there's a lot of
opportunity
yeah and your passion is in business is
it you're studying business uh yeah so
i'm
lucky i got into the uh cali school but
that's one of the main reasons i wanted
to come
uh to the us but then specifically
indiana um
because there's i think the average
starting salary of a
just like an undergrad students like 70
000 usd from the business school
like it's seen as pretty like
prestigious and that
so i hope to
graduate here
i'm trying to graduate in three years or
three and a half years so earlier than
four years and then get like my mba paid
for
and then obviously football doesn't work
out
uh hopefully i'll land a pretty good job
either here or back home
so what's your what's your week look
like at the moment obviously it sounds
like you're pretty much a full-time
uh professional
uh american football player but you've
also got to manage your study
in between that what's your study to
training ratio sort of look like what's
a week look like
uh well right now we're not in season so
it's
it's pretty relaxed so right now it's uh
monday wednesday friday left
thursday
like team runs and then i'm expected to
go kick balls on my own like two or
three times
and then
i'm in a lot of credit hours right now
so i've taken seven classes a semester
so
um
usually at monday through thursday i've
had three classes and then
friday i'd have one class in the morning
off the left
but in this season it's it's a lot more
hectic it's
it was a lot of days where i'd be waking
up at six to come to football football
would finish it like 11 30 12 and then
i'd go to classroom one till 6 30
and then i'd have tutoring or homework
and a lot of times i wouldn't get home
till 9 or 10 p.m so
yeah it was it was kind of a lot and
then on the weekend would be expected to
go
to go play
um
so it can be stressful at times but
it's all worth it
that is crazy and what's like the whole
college environment like is um you
obviously see a lot in the movies over
here that's pretty much as far as we go
um here in new zealand with what it's
like is it like the movies is that are
you guys sort of the big dogs of the
campus as a american football player
uh i mean there's definitely like some
i don't know if you you know people know
you play football they might treat you
slightly differently um
but i don't know we have a good time on
the side
you know outside of football in school
um
it's been like pretty crazy with some of
the things uh
like bars frats and all those uh kind of
things
it's actually funny though because back
home i was
legal to drink you know and then i came
here and i was 19. um it was my first
day
i was at lax i was really tired
and i was like well i'll go buy a beer
like
like i've got i've got to wait like six
hours at the airport
and so went out to the kiosk and i was
like can i get like a bud light or
something
like can i see some id and i showed my
new zealand driver's license and
well i'm 19. so
yes that was
that was the first time or else
yeah i learned i learned the hard way
but
yeah luckily i'm turning 21 uh
next month so
you'll be into it
yeah
in terms of like the college thing do
you have like initiations and things
like the rugby is there is a squad
really close do you guys all get down
the piss together much or not really
such a big group hey um
yeah it's there's a lot of dudes there's
not really an initiation uh thing at all
um
i guess a lot of uh my friends are in
like the class kind of like so people
are like recruited in a
like the football team
um
every year so everyone kind of comes in
the same time so like i'm friends with a
lot of those guys um
and so those a lot of the guys that um
ordered things like socially together
um
outside of that though like all the guys
are really really um really cool dudes
there's a lot of i guess like diverse
backgrounds it's
kind of weird obviously i'm like a
foreigner but we actually have another
dude on the team that
uh ceo he was born in
auckland actually
uh lived there till he was eight
then moved to australia and then i know
he moved to american samoa then
australia in the us
um but he's a defensive tackle he
actually does athletic things
so
yeah
so aft after a game
do you guys all just head back to the
change rooms to head off to
your classic american house party what's
uh what's the usual ritual after a game
ah
it depends if it's an away game shower
get dressed call my parents
get on the bus get to a plane fly home
everything's really streamlined if it's
a home game
uh
i guess just
find out what we're doing afterwards and
go enjoy the boys company um
there was one time though actually we
played
michigan state it was a noon game
really big game sold out game
um
and what happened was after the game
like this you know what tailgating is
yeah
yeah so one of uh
teammates families had a tailgate gave
me like a couple beers
and i was like oh no like i had an exam
to take that 8 p.m that night
so
it was it was rough
uh so we played in the game in front of
53 000 and probably a couple million on
tv and then
i was in a
like computer and business so like
pretty rough exam
at 8 pm that night
um
so i don't know that it varies a lot but
um
we definitely like enjoy enjoy ourselves
um
you have to yeah so then like post game
do you guys how much of a how much
analysis do you do as a kicker uh in
terms of who you're playing how does
your review sort of preview work look
um so saturday we play sunday we come in
we have a lift treatment
and we review our film from the
day before and then we have a
walkthrough which is like
just walking through
things to improve and then also
walking through the opposition for the
next week uh and then we've got monday
off
from football and then tuesday
a big meeting and we'll review um
everything like for me
uh last season all i had to know was uh
what kind of looks they'll give me uh
like their pun return unit
so if they will overload one side and
i'll know i have to get the wall off
slightly quicker or if it's a hold up
look um so for me and everything's kind
of just like our special teams
coordinator will do
all that and they'll put in a report and
they'll kind of go through it and then
occasionally i'd watch um
film if i was unsure but
uh a lot of the time it's pretty
self-explanatory like
for me if i see
like a significant overload on what like
the kick side it'll probably mean to
bring pressure
um
and then send teams brings it and look
sir how hard was that for you to learn
all that side of things especially since
you hadn't watched much you hadn't
followed much football
through your
life i guess growing up how hard was it
to pick up all these cues and understand
the game where to put the ball uh
not not really too difficult uh just
because a lot of it was set out by our
coordinator
and he took me through it a lot
and then obviously we have play calls
for where we're kicking what type of
kick all those things um
so really especially because it's my
first year
i didn't have a whole lot of
responsibility in terms of like decision
making and that it was really just he
told me what to do
and
if i saw something like pre-snap
i might
instead of taking like a full like three
steps just like one step and get it off
um
which should happen a couple of times
especially some teams like when they
know there's like a freshman back there
they'll
you know
they'll try to come after you a bit but
yeah it wasn't it wasn't like nothing
nothing terribly difficult especially
when
the offense and the defensive play books
are like brutal
like they're always in meetings and a
lot of the time like we have to be at
football but we're not in an o d meeting
so we're just
in the players lounge like playing ping
pong or whatever um
so
yeah
yeah so all your all your team stuff's
done separately all the ds done by
themselves all the attacks done by
themselves and you guys do your own
stuff as well so it's all pretty split
is it
uh yeah so
i mean the kickers punters and snappers
are kind of like the three position
or positions where like
we're kind of almost separate um
and then special teams so we have uh
punt punt return kickoff and kickoff for
ten and then field go field goal blocks
so those are the six units we have um
and so
basically the offensive and defensive
play is depending on what unit it is
will play
in the special team
they'll just be they're like blocking or
trying to make a tackle or trying to
block a kick
so they'll still have to come to the
same meetings as us
it's just
they'll also have to land like an entire
offense or a tight defense and then
we'll just be
chilling
in the plays lounge waiting waiting for
them to be done so we can go home so how
much of your job uh relies on your
teammates your other guys
uh for me quite a lot so basically
i mean if they don't do their job and
protection then i'm probably gonna get
smacked um
which is not ideal
and then
in terms of coverage uh
getting off blocks uh
getting down either like forcing like a
fair catch like the gunner oh sorry the
return i can
signal to basically
say we're not going to return the ball
i'm just going to catch it so it doesn't
roll
um
and then the offense is going to start
from where if they caught it
so either doing that like getting
downfield quickly and forcing a fair
catch or um
making tackles in open field if they get
a return so
uh
they do a lot they don't really get much
credit which is uh
unfortunate um
but yeah really they playing special
teams
uh
there's not a whole lot of glory um
and it's kind of just one of those
things where
you're just getting smacked for a little
little return you know so
the battles on special teams you got to
appreciate them and go thank them so and
you mentioned before about like you get
you got told what sort of kick to um put
in before you run out there so what sort
of kicks is that like what do they
usually want from you is it hang time is
it length is that a combination of all
sorts of things um
so
distance hang time uh direction and get
off are probably like the four main
things um
but then obviously we have different
types of kicks so there's like calls
depending on how like protection schemes
um
so we'll never kick down the middle of
the field
unless i miss hit a ball um
so
uh
there's left directional kicks right
directional kicks uh if we're close to
like the goal line so i have to kick
with precision
um
we'll have like end over n kicks uh
something we didn't use as much uh last
year but uh basically like
rolling rugby style like end of rand
kicks
that's pretty popular
in college football a lot of australian
guys they do that a lot
um
i find that's like really easy to do
like in a wind yeah
um so those are really the main uh
calls and then obviously
based off of what the other team's doing
uh there was times last year where i had
to just catch it and just one step it's
basically just take one step and kick it
and you haven't you don't do any kicking
for gold do you
uh no so
that's actually my roommate charles uh
he's he's out starting field with a
kicker um
i've started getting reps uh holding for
field goals
uh this year
so maybe in the season i'll be the
starting holder so is that the catcher
and then put it down yeah put it down um
so that's
i don't know it's it's not too difficult
it's
um
nice to get a bit more responsibility
and something else to do a practice yeah
um
yeah would you like to get into the uh
goalkeeping uh
no i just don't think i could do it and
really there's not
too much point so no one would do both
in the nfl you just choose your lane
no no there's a few dudes that do it uh
like the college level uh like the penn
state guy
uh john stout was phenomenal or both um
but in the nfl they have a separate guy
for for both so it's so so specialized
day such a specialized game just
come on for you yeah
get on off so good
i know well we've spoken a little bit
about the facilities and um
from what i've seen in the photos it
just looks next level like you're you're
german that whole side of things it's so
professional
um you don't get paid i know everything
gets paid for but
um
what's what's the facilities like what's
it like training there
uh
obviously they're really really nice i'm
in the stadium right now
in the academic center
um and it's really nice here because
everything's uh in the stadium are
attached to the stadium so we have
an athlete academic center an athlete
dining hall
uh
a general athlete like physical therapy
room
uh elf football locker room which is
really really nice i like football plays
lounge which just has a bunch like free
food and then
a bunch of unnecessary things like ping
pong and pool
uh
we've got hot tubs cold tubs a bunch of
other recovery stuff
like a football only physical therapy
room
position meeting rooms
a weight room and then obviously we got
the the main game field uh two practice
fields and an indoor practice facility
um
so there's a lot yeah there's
a lot of things so i i end up spending a
lot of time at the stadium
and it's kind of nice that everything's
going in one place
um
fair enough and none of none of the
players get paid do they or is there
some sort of like endorsements and
things that they can get now or is it
just
yeah so basically i think it's july or
last year they they open it up uh
something called nils the name engine
likeness so players can start getting
paid
uh from
endorsements and all that kind of stuff
so i actually can't get paid though
because i'm on a student visa
um so i'm not able to accept any of that
but
um
there's definitely a lot of money in
college football
um this is a lot of dudes making around
like america some dudes making like in
the millions just from endorsements um
yeah i don't know our basketball team
there's definitely a couple of dudes
making like a few hundred thousand
um
i don't know exactly how much some of my
teammates are making but i know like
some of them making in the tens of
thousands
[Music]
so it's good
side gig and i guess it kind of
even though it like the wording of it's
like you can't
incentivize like how you play but
um
it kind of is you know so the better you
play like the bigger your brand's gonna
be and then the more opportunities
you're going to get yeah and it sounds
like an awesome place to be a coach as
well he's on a fair wicket oh yeah no
our head coach
makes a lot he's got a really nice house
we've been in his house
yeah it would be nice uh all that
stuff's uh public though
so i guess
people can look it up if
if they're curious but
it's yeah in the millions
yeah crazy hey like
as and how how many coaches have you got
like are they all on millions or is it
just the head guy who has to front
everything
his head's on the line i guess yeah it's
the head guy i guess we have a head
coach offensive defense and special
teams coordinator and then we have um
position coaches quarterbacks coach
where i receive his coach all the
different positions as a coach for
them um and then underneath that there's
i think called like quality control
so just below position coaches and
there's i think it's like five
five of those and then
we have a graduate assistant so
basically
guys that are in
grad school
well they've paid to be football coaches
but also they're in grad school and so
like they're getting their graduate
education
and then we have student assistants as
well fairly big team
yeah there's a lot
yeah no definitely
oh there's so much money yeah i think
well i read somewhere that it was you
guys made 30 million or was it more than
that uh
yeah i think so i think 2019 roughly 30
million in profit just a football
department i'd like to think that would
have gone up uh last year just with
attendance
um
but yeah no it's pretty crazy when you
think about it yeah and how did your
team do last year oh we uh
did not we didn't have a great season uh
we actually won two games out and had 10
losses um
yeah unfortunately we had a lot of
momentum going into the season i think
we were the ranked number 17 in the
country going into the season
um
but a couple
we lost first game at iowa
uh week three we lost to cincinnati we
were in the college full playoff week
five we lost at penn state
and just early season uh bad momentum
combined with a lot of injuries the key
guys kind of just
yeah so that obviously doesn't affect
attendance so it's not like new zealand
like when your team starts losing that
crowd stopped coming you guys were
losing what you're two from 10 and
you're still getting 110 000 to the
stadium
oh
yeah no well i mean definitely the last
couple home games weren't as uh
when it's packed but what so it was it
gets really cold here i think
it was 25 degrees fahrenheit who both
have lost two home games so
i want to say it's like negative three
negative four degrees celsius so
fair enough no one's tuning up
yeah so
i mean yeah i wouldn't i probably
wouldn't go if i was a fan
yeah that's that's probably one of the
the worst things about living in indiana
um
the coldest it's got since that being
has like negative 20 degrees celsius
um
and then it's gone into the 40s in the
summer so like
there's just no happy like medium like
it is kind of back home so how do you
keep warm like that's a interesting
point around like when it's that cold
and you're only kicking six times and
you're doing a lot of standing around on
that sideline aren't you so how are you
keeping your leg warm and uh ready to
kick uh well luckily we've heated
benches when it's cold so i just sit on
the heated bench which is nice uh
and then like towards the end of the
season as it got colder i'd
hop on the bike and
kick balls with a kicking net so kick
into the net
[Music]
but you know it got to the point last
season where i guess it's kind of like
deep heat
uh pain zone it was titled where i like
our athletic trainers i'd be like i need
some pain zone i just chucked on like my
hamstrings
so i'd be feeling warm and loose you
know oh jeez it's good stuff so
interesting and you spoke about your
side not having a great year um last
year but what's what's the future look
like for them
i'd like to think
uh definitely gonna have a better year
this year um
i feel like last year we just
the lecs and losses combined with
injuries the key guys kind of just
you know when you're on a team and you
lose the momentum that you had going
into the season and
the people's confidence gets affected
and
everything just you know is on a steady
decline
but uh through like our spring football
program and our
winter conditioning program things been
looking good um
i guess we got some new like trance was
in
uh so a lot of those guys are looking
good and
i definitely feel like this year the
team is more
together
off the field and hopefully that'll
uh kind of translate to on-field uh
performance
yeah and how much does the team rely on
your quarterback like seems like a lot
when you're watching for with a you know
an eye which isn't tuned into american
football but
how much do you guys rely on your
quarterback
well i guess like the whole like offense
goes through the quarterback so quite
quite a lot um yeah
so that was one of the things last year
that kind of affected us just
we had a lot of injuries to our
quarterbacks and
um
got to the point with the end of the
season where um
we were down an 18 year old freshman who
uh had only actually been
you know with the team for like a few
months so
you know he's a really really talented
player but like it's kind of throwing a
kid into the
you know the far early i think um
so yeah i mean the games that we won the
quarterback play was really good um
i think mike when we played against
western kentucky and we beat them in
their home he threw for like nearly like
400 yards which is a lot um
decided upon much that game
which was nice um
but
yeah no it's it's a lot they have a lot
of responsibility um
like i don't really envy being them you
know
uh yeah especially when it comes to how
much like film they get to watch and how
much uh like of the playbook they have
to study and all those things
yeah so do they come up with them with a
lot of their tax strategy or is that
still the head coach who gives it to
them but they just need to
keep an eye on things
uh so i think it's just all through the
offensive coordinator like i'm still
like kind of not so privy to all those
things and not
so informed but the offensive
coordinator it's his job to like call
plays and all those things so he
uh does all that
um
and he calls the plays and so then it's
i think it's like signals that go to the
quarterback and then the quarterback
uh tells the rest of the guys and all
those
to be honest with you i'd not 100
percent informed on how this works yeah
i just gotta kick the ball
yeah
so what so what's the plan of severe
you've got yeah three years um
over there to get through what's the
dream to get drafted how do you go about
the process to get drafted what's the
what's the plans
yeah so i still have
uh three more years to play um
i guess yeah the dream would be to play
in the nfl
and to get there it's probably just
being more consistent on the field and
continuing to develop and get better and
all those
things like i'm still really young i'm
only 20
and i've only been kicking footballs
just like two and a half years now so
like i'm still very early on in my
development so just
keeping on developing um
as a punter
and then as i get older just continue to
play and play better um
but it's it's definitely hard to get
into the nfl as a partner because
there's only 32 spots
so
i mean there's only really like three to
five spots that kind of come for each
year so you have to be
really up there in college football and
really performing um
obviously i want to graduate
hopefully get my mba
and a football doesn't work out
honestly i don't know if i'll stay in
the us
post graduation i get asked that like
all the time
but i guess there's a few factors
[Music]
maybe get a job in finance and move to
chicago or something but
that's all very
in the future you know so
yeah so much to happen between now and
then a it's interesting that so if you
miss out on the draft initially could
you get picked up later on even though
you're not playing college football or
is once you miss that
transition are you pretty much done
no you can uh i mean if you don't get
drafted you can sign as an undrafted
free agent and then this opportunity is
to try out for teams
um
there's also other opportunities like
there's the canadian football leagues
there's a professional league so there's
a lot of
they have a international draft i think
so there's opportunities for guys um
overseas to go play in that
um
so that could be an option if things go
well
there's other leagues
uh like spring football leagues where
guys like go play and then
hope you know they play well get like
good game film and then get signed by an
nfl team um
but you know there's definitely
opportunities and there's like stories
of guys that didn't make it initially
and then just stuck with it and then um
you know a few years of development on
their own and training yeah
got to that point is that something
you'd like to do or do you think you'd
chase the um go down the business side
oh
i really don't know to be honest with
you i think
i'd be trying to be as realistic as
possible but if it was feasible you know
i'd like to give it
you know a run
um yeah i feel like
especially if it was uh there was like a
good uh possibility that it could happen
you know i feel like i'd regret it if i
didn't but
yeah that's the question for like three
or four years from now yeah to be honest
with you
yeah
mate it's so fascinating such an
interesting story it's so cool to hear
but as always we have gone to our
instagram for some questions and uh it
looks like a couple of your mates might
be following the waterlab page which is
good stuff so we've had a few good
questions coming but the first question
is from another lad what's the
difference between part punting in
american football in a rugby ball this
one came from simon hickey so
another noted rugby ball punter
um
well college football is slightly
smaller than
the nfl ball is slightly bigger uh so
the sweet spot is smaller um
kicking it like end over end is
like a rock will go further
so but they spiral pretty well so if you
if you get the technique down and you
hit the sweet spot they'll like they'll
fly um
definitely especially compared to rugby
balls like smiling a rock balls pretty
hard i feel like they don't actually
you know spiral too well um yeah
but yeah andover and punting is a lot
easier with a rugby ball and it's
probably easier to control as well
like a lot of our game balls are really
pointy
at the ends because they're pretty new
um so they can be pretty brutal
and a run kick
interesting so how far could you punt a
nfl ball oh
like no when are we talking no
yeah no
oh you can put a gale behind you if you
want give us a good stat
uh i don't know i probably got videos
from you hitting it uh
like 70 75 meters on the fall
um but with some wind uh
i don't know whatever depending on the
wind um yeah
100 meters no i don't know about that
when you really get behind the ball um
and it spirals
and you hit it with like a low
trajectory like it can fly
um so
yeah yeah what about a rugby ball how
far could you punt to rugby paul
i don't know i haven't kicked a rugby
line
probably good three
four years now uh
i don't know what's kind of the standard
like 50 55 60
probably not as far as you could heyday
you'd have me easy right i don't know
about that
the little wedge out
ah good stuff okay next one how far
could you place kick a rugby ball
oh
one time when i was 15 i hit one 60
meters
uh
i think 17 i hit probably 64 but that
was kind of the most um
that was probably a good bit that was
with a good bit of wind though so
i don't know
but you obviously haven't done it for a
while
no no i feel like i'd be terrible if i
tried giving it a crack
yeah one of our coaches uh is a big
rugby fan
and we actually had like a rugby wall
like randomly turn up in our indoor
and he was trying to get get me to
give it a go recently
but
yeah
oh i love that okay next one um sort of
spoke about this one we're talking about
marty banks but which rugby player do
you think would have the best chance of
making it in the nfl as a kicker
i feel like dan carter back in his
heyday um he'd be pretty good as a like
a field goal kicker
um
because he used a very low teeth in
there yeah
yeah you got to kick it's it's weird
because you kick off the ground it's
kind of difficult that's why i kind of
suck it
at kicking feel goes but you used to
have it up on the big high tee
i don't know about that but
i definitely wasn't as ambitious as he
was uh with the low t um
but there's a good few people and
trying to think i don't actually get to
catch too much rugby in the present day
just because the time difference is i'm
hoping a couple weeks ago i'll be able
to catch some games
um
maybe i'll just give a shout out mighty
banks
he showed he showed he showed some good
potential um
that one time i was kicking balls with
them oh he's he's i reckon he's gonna
fly over soon and give it a crack he'd
love it
rugby career is coming to an end
come try and be an nfl player
oh how good what about as a um
just as a player like um any rugby
players who you think would go good as a
running back or any other position
i guess running back's the main one that
people
or kick return is the ones main ones
that they try
probably probably someone in the
midfield or a fullback um
maybe ma nono in his prime put him at
running back and get him to
smoke some dudes up front um
but yeah i don't know being a running
back is brutal like seeing the dude who
started last year steven carr
after games like
it couldn't be me
yeah
yeah if you guys have tried it did you
follow much of like jared hayne and um
christian wade and their
um attempts to crack it
i like it a tiny bit um
it's hard though like especially as a
position player
um like obviously in rugby a condition
to like play 80 minutes and
um
like aerobically and whatnot
um
and i go from that to the stop start and
having to know like
200 different plays
sometimes even more than that i think i
really don't know
it's kind of difficult in learning like
i feel like if if a lot of those guys a
lot of guys playing professional rugby
like right now grew up in america
and had the opportunities um
you know at a younger age they'd be
they'd be killing it right now but
it's just yeah it's a tough gig to pick
up i feel like so late
yeah agree okay next one if you could
this one's from our sponsor swoosh if
you could get a video message from any
celebrity in the world who would it be
and why
jeez
i feel like uh cristiano ronaldo
just talked yeah
just
absolute stud
probably the best i'll say the best
stock player of all time um
do you follow much soccer
uh like a tiny bit to be honest with you
like i don't really follow much sport in
general just because of like how hectic
things are
um
and then
just sometimes it feels i don't know if
you were the same sometimes it feels
weird when you're like around sports so
much to
to follow it but
like a tiny bit when i can
fair enough cristiano ronaldo absolutely
he'd go go on the podcast too actually
okay next one what made you pick the
number 69 are you are you actually
number 69
no no no i'm
i'm number 94 and basically
because i play a pretty irrelevant
position
actually i was going to be number 99
because the special teams coordinator
was like you can pick a number in the
90s and that's going to be your number
so i was like sweet ass let's pick 99.
and then
he forgot to tell the equipment guys and
i went on twitter one day and it was
like new
uh
players numbers and it was 94 and i was
like well i guess i'm 94 now
so
so you get no saying that
obviously uh i mean not not real i mean
if i was like at the start quarterback
yeah like i could probably go
demand to be
a sexy number but
no
oh that's good stuff okay next one if
you could play with any current player
who would it be
oh
maybe uh tom brady
has to be doesn't that yeah oh you and
tom brady yeah i mean also i wouldn't be
i wouldn't be punting a whole lot as
well with tom brady so it'd be a nice
little gig just chill on the sidelines
sideline tickets and then
get on the field a couple times so the
better your team is the less you punt
essentially yeah so we planted a lot
last season
big year for the freshman just punting
all the time
yeah
kate
unfortunately
more questions who's your dream nfl
draft team who would you love to be
drafted by
oh
i don't know i just went to uh
like miami fort lauderdale for spring
break and that was a really really good
time so maybe the dolphins
no income oh no state income tax there
as well
um
state income taxes yeah it was really
warm there a really good time um
my favorite team is the tennessee titans
uh in nashville so i've been there a
couple times that was another good time
um
we actually worked out with a couple
dudes on the titans that was that was
cool they're really nice dudes but
i don't know
i'd i'd go wherever wherever they were
paying me you spoke about spring break
there what was that like
oh that was uh that was probably the
longest week of my life but
it was a good time yeah
what is like how big is that like how
many people are at spring break is it oh
it was unreal it was um
everywhere was packed like beaches
bars every like the whole
like you knew as well
you knew like what schools were on
spring break like you just go talk to
people and they'd all be from the same
like
six to eight schools so
but it was hectic that's probably the
longest week of my life do you have to
go to school to go there or is any uh
heaps of people there no
no no anyone can just show up but um
for the most part like
it's just um
just school
school kids yeah that's crazy sounds
good stuff okay last question best piece
of advice you have for a waterlet
listener
i guess
uh from my unique
uh standing and how weird my life's kind
of panned out
um
you know if there is something you want
to do just go out and
try to do it and
it works out it works out if not
maybe have a good time out of it but
yeah
i mean that's
that is kind of how my life uh worked
out weirdly you know um
and so i'm pretty grateful to be in the
position i'm in and
you know i'd i'd advise everyone to
go after what they want and
hope for the best give it a crack love
that and mate you're you're right you're
spot on like your career or your journey
has been so interesting and so unique
and it's been such a fascinating insight
for me someone i've wanted to
have a yarn to for a long time just to
hear about how you've come about this um
gig over there and mates super
interesting stuff really fascinating um
for me to hear the inside into
what it's like over there as a american
football player and in college football
so really appreciate you coming on the
podcast and man i'm really looking
forward to following your career from
here and um seeing how you go
no thank you so much for having me
mate you're a lad you know thank you